[Music]
you're in in terrific shape you're uh
you like fitness you're into fitness
you're a proponent of hot yoga i love
hot yoga
i'm fascinated by hot yoga i've never
done it right i don't know what's this
what do you mean well
that's rude
i don't know i just want no does your
body move
i know do you have a body no it's not
you it's not you it's just that my my
mom started getting into it and when you
told me you you've never done it before
you have to brace yourself because she
called me she said i'm going to hot yoga
i know you do hot yoga all the time and
i really you know she does her zumba
already so she wanted to add something
else on to it i said well mom just be
careful no no it's going to be fine and
she called me back and she said after
the class i said so how did it go she
goes well i threw up twice
and you'd be really proud of your mother
just seems like it's something in your
family because you're like
yeah i don't know if she doesn't like
that when you go anywhere i went to the
museum threw up no biggie yeah no biggie
um and so she goes oh i threw up choice
and i'm like oh every time any time you
hear your mom was like no nothing
happened
yeah it was too much for her and then
she said but i'm at least she would be
very proud of me i'm very talented i can
throw up and drive at the same time
that's disgusting oh yeah it was really
gross what's the trick there is a cup
holder yeah that's what i said i said i
don't understand how did you do that she
said you just grab the towel throw it on
your lap and you just you know
no
no
you pull over
and you get sick on the side of the road
you know
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm done i'm sorry i wanted to see how
long we could just go
we just did nine minutes of that
people would start it would be
fascinating we could have our own weird
cable channel uh
is hot yoga difficult uh
is it something cause you made a face
and i think you initially made the face
because you don't think i could do it is
it something that i could actually do
is it is it it gets your body really hot
so your muscles get looser and you can
do things you normally couldn't do
i'm getting uncomfortable no yes you
could do it i think you could do it i
think you could do it in your heart okay
you can just breathe
i think you would be fine okay i think
you are tall enough
that's not a prerequisite of yoga
your hair is red enough you're limber
enough yeah
no i'm not limber enough you could i've
seen
yeah you're right yeah that's that's
yeah going to get me through hot yoga
i think he'd be fine oh thank you you
can come with me anytime is that true
really yeah right i'm going to take you
up on that we can throw up together no
stop bringing that up